joe biden knows this race is almost run
now on the line whether his political
career
ends this week or if he is destined to
become america's 46th
president the polls say victory is
within reach
his focus on the state of his birth
pennsylvania
will be decisive everybody knows who
donald trump is
but we're about honor integrity
dignity is the united states of america
we gotta let them show who we are
we choose we choose hope over fear
we choose unity over division
joe biden's come here to beaver county
in pennsylvania
because it is one of those places that
was always reliably democrat
but voted for donald trump in 2016. if
he can flip a place like this
it will tell a much bigger story about
what's happening in this election
the mix of suburban voters those who sat
out the last election and wavering trump
supporters
is his target across the country you
find most of them on jenny lin drive
the dueling signs reveal a community
like the country
engaged as never before we've never been
politically involved
never put a yard sign on our property to
me
he will seek people out and he truly
cares about them
whereas president trump does not
bob served in vietnam and was a democrat
until trump came along
i've been through wars i'm a veteran i
know
when i see somebody i honestly believe
in
i'm putting all my trust in that person
and i really have a lot of trust in
trump
he's done everything that he said he's
going to do
and that's basically what the people of
western pennsylvania
they just feel that they can trust trump
up the road ron speaks for many i just
hope
that it doesn't come down to this like
uh questioning the election
you know is is did everything go right
you know is somebody trying to
you know sway the election by some
some means and we shouldn't be there we
shouldn't be at that point we should be
electing a president
[Applause]
[Music]
it is the president who's been talking
up election chaos and legal challenges
another sweep through multiple states
took him to joe biden's hometown of
scranton pennsylvania make sure your
governor doesn't cheat
okay if you're good because they're
known for very bad things
very very bad things here can you
imagine the pollsters saying
you have to allow five percent in
pennsylvania for cheating that's a
terrible thing to say
of course everybody knows it's true no
but we have a lot of eyes watching they
never had eyes watching we got a lot of
very powerful eyes watching them
and already more than 90 million
americans have had their say
record-breaking early voting a
reflection of a pandemic
but also intense interest
and the future this country is about to
choose greg milam sky news
[Music]
pennsylvania